♪ (music) ♪
Hi, everybody, and welcome
to TensorFlow Meets.
It's my great honor today
to be chatting with Megan Kacholia,
Engineering Director, right?
on TensorFlow.
So can you tell us a little bit more
about what it is that you do?
Sure. I'm an Engineering Director
on the TensorFlow team.
I've been with the team for a little
over two-and-a-half years now.
I've gotten to participate
in all of the Dev Summits
- which has been really exciting.
- Nice.
Just to get to come, be part
of the keynote, be part of the event.
In terms of what I actually do,
I'm one of the leads
for the TensorFlow team.
I just help with, obviously,
the team itself,
make sure we're going
in the right direction,
and make sure that we're doing
the right things by our community.
One of the things that you spoke about
that I saw that a lot of people
are excited about
and I know I'm personally excited about
is just really how we're doubling down
on making it very developer-friendly
- in TensorFlow.
- Yes.
How do that come about,
can you tell us a bit more about it?
Obviously we've taken
a lot of feedback from the community,
just to see what are the pain points,
what works well, what doesn't,
I think that's a big part of it.
And just in general TensorFlow
has been around--
We just had our third birthday
in November, right?
So, things change, or the industry
is really moving quickly,
machine learning is advancing
in lots of different places
than we might have anticipated
when TensorFlow was first developed.
So we need to make sure
that we're making it very, very easy
for folks to just come in, get started,
and be able to take advantage
of all of the cool things happening
- in the machine learning space.
- Right.
I really think it comes
from kind of both of those angles,
just how things have moved so fast,
and just the feedback
we've gotten from the community
as we've had TensorFlow
out there for a few years.
I've been working on it
for about a year and a half
and I came in with a developer background
and when I started trying
to kick the tires on TensorFlow,
there were some things
where it was like...
it just wasn't quite intuitive to me.
But a lot of that
has been changing, right?
There's stuff like Keras
- and other things,
- That's correct.
and the eager execution
by default that you've been adding
just hopefully will make it
a lot easier for other developers.
(Megan) That's correct.
We want to make sure, obviously,
that the flexibility and the power
of TensorFlow is there,
but also make sure it's approachable
and easy for people to just come in
and be like, it's fine,
start here on this surface,
and if you need to dive down to this part
and really get into the guts of it,
you can, it's fantastic,
but you don't have to
if you don't need to.
(Laurence) Right.
And all of this doesn't come
at the cost of performance, right?
Because you had that great slide
with performance and...
Can you tell us a little bit
about the performance improvements
that you've been seeing with TensorFlow?
(Megan) So a lot of those
improvements as well
while we're looking at just
kind of the core TensorFlow, right,
kind of you think of like the heart of it,
and that's where the majority
of the improvements come,
meaning that those improvements
will be applicable
whether we're talking
about TensorFlow 2.0
or whether we're talking about
using Keras or something else.
It's that big meaty part
kind of under the hood.
And a lot of it comes
from just better making use
of the different types of hardware,
making sure that we're using the different
types of accelerators appropriately,
understanding the limitations
and restrictions for things like mobile.
We talked about a lot of improvements
for performance on TF Lite as well,
and again, some of it
is just understanding
what do the [workflows] really look like,
what does it look like
on some of these different devices
and Edge TPUs and things that we're trying
in TensorFlow out more with now,
and then kind of always going back
and closing the loop and being like,
okay, this is how we can make it better
and this is how we can make sure
that the users get
that performance by default,
and don't have to necessarily know
what magic had to happen
under the covers for it to happen,
they should just get it.
(Laurence) Right. Now, you mentioned
a mobile with TensorFlow Lite.
We lovingly call it TF Lite.
One of the things that I do get
a lot of questions about
is that there's all of these different
almost parts of the family of TensorFlow,
and can you give us a quick summary
of the different runtimes
that are available for developers,
between TensorFlow Lite and,
what are those other?
(Megan) So there's TensorFlow Lite,
there's more higher level types of things
that we talked about
with TensorFlow Extended,
so that's not neccessarily
a different runtime
but it's more kind of just how
you put things together end to end,
especially if you're looking more
towards a production environment.
We talked a bit about JavaScript as well,
so TensorFlow.js,
and I think that one,
it's a language-type thing,
because you want to make sure
that the JavaScript community--
it's such a large community--
that they have access
to machine learning as well,
but there's also just
the whole in-browser experience
that it plugs in well with
because of Node.js.
So I think a lot of it depends
on what kind of applications
people are interested in
and kind of where they're coming
at machine learning from.
There are so many different ways
of applying machine learning,
whether you're thinking of it like,
"Oh, I work in a large company,
so I need it for
these enterprise use cases,"
or "I'm just an app developer,
I'm trying things out myself,"
or "I'm someone who's really
familiar with this language,
I'm really familiar with JavaScript,
so that means I can use that
as kind of my entryway
to start doing other things
in machine learning."
So some of it depends on where you're at,
where you're coming from,
and then we try and make sure
we have the right way for you
to get into the machine
learning community.
The JavaScript stuff
is amazing in the fact
that you can actually
train models in the browser.
(Megan) Yes.
When I first heard about that,
I was like "Nah, come on, really?"
- But you actually can do that, so...
- (Megan) Yes, it's really cool.
And as you mentioned that with Node
you're not just limited to in the browser,
you can also run it on backend servers
and that kind of stuff.
One of my personal favorites actually,
is with things like Cloud Functions
or Cloud Functions for Firebase
because they run Node.js,
you can actually start
putting models in there.
Now, TensorFlow 2.0 is currently
an alpha release, right?
Now, lots of people are asking
what comes next,
when are we going to see a release
candidate or something like that?
Yeah, so like we talked about
at the Dev Summit,
we're going to have our release candidate
kind of coming up sometime in Q2.
We want to make sure
that we're giving ourselves
enough time to make sure
we have good performance,
make sure we have the right fit,
finish, and polish for everything,
but there is, like you said,
an alpha available.
We want feedback from the community.
We want to understand
what are people enjoying,
what's working well,
what are they concerned about.
And you can also follow along on GitHub
and kind of see
what features are coming out,
what status are things at.
That way the community
knows what's going on
and we can make sure
that we're engaged appropriately
to be building the right things
as we finalize and finish up
with the 2.0 release.
Sound perfect. Thank you!
So people can stay tuned to GitHub
and keep track of everything
- that's going on.
- (Megan) Yeah, that's correct.
Thank you so much, Megan.
And thanks, everybody, for watching
this episode of TensorFlow Meets.
If you got any questions for me
or any questions for Megan,
just please leave them
in the comments below,
and check out the GitHub page
for TensorFlow
if you want to learn more
about the TensorFlow 2.0 release.
Thank you so much.
♪ (music) ♪